hi everybody my name is markiplier and
welcome to let's play the world's
hardest game - again with a speech
jammer and if you're like what is the
speech jammer I have to explain it
before I turned on
actually no I'm just gonna go ahead and
turn on to see how it goes from yourself
as you can probably could probably tell
I turned on I turned on the I turned on
the speech jammer at a speech jammer is
a device that loops your own voice but
your own voice into your ears on a Dilla
day so that you can't understand you
can't understand when you're done
talking so it makes a baby that it makes
it very hard to do come on Harry
well before God we were out to do I
already played this before but I had to
turn off the off the audio because I
have to have by but I have to have I
have my voice at a very loud volume and
in order in order to be able to play the
game and hear myself so you can't you
can't hear the game thereby baby I mean
I may add some looping music afterwards
in order to give some ambience if I talk
slowly
I can talk normally I'm going oh this is
absolutely this is absolutely this is
absolutely ridiculous because I heard I
saw this on out I saw this on another
another the video I had I thought that I
thought that there was going to be a
good idea but I could tell that I've
ever been I made I made I made I I made
I made a huge mistake in this decision
to do this
then this stupid speech jammer thing
what try to play pick a rage game this
has got to be the dumbest the dumbest
identity beer that I've ever heard my
life it's absolutely ridiculous because
I've already bar I've already getting
frustrated because I can't because I
can't talk and I want to talk I'm dress
I had to trench which Twitter by I the
other had the I had to switch to my
other other had the headphones because
these ones are closed year whereas my oh
boy where's my new headphones are open
ear Oriole and and they would not work a
programmer in for appropriate
appropriate ly because I would then be
able to hear outside my ears Isis how I
sound like one of the guy from oh um
from from when they were doing the dub
the one they were doing the double voice
in improv in propaganda and what they
were doing it was a zero trial they were
trying to spit
I don't sound like anyone at all oh I
don't even said that I don't think I've
literally never sound like myself I
can't believe I do are you or didn't
think you wouldn't think that it
wouldn't met you better but you have to
have to have yours levy volume way up so
that you could only hear your own voice
you gotta tell someone
this is awful anyway let's get back it
like back to the to the into the
importance of the game yeah we did we
baby bees another with this we beat
another level but when I were both now
we're bad now we're back to the level
that we were beginning it did it we're
gonna get to the other that we're gonna
get to do
we're getting will get again into the
levels that stumped us before and now
that we're we're completely unable to
speed I can't believe that I died I'm
not even I'm not even I'm not even
talking about the game right now because
I'm so focused on what's happening
what's happening in my ear balls I don't
have ear balls no one has it here no no
but no one hasn't has ear balls what
they have I'm looking at these balls in
the game
I can't I'm gonna kill some this is
absolute this is the Diavolo
this is the absolute little work this is
the absolute worst idea I have ever I've
ever had I think I've said that before
but it is more true than it ever was and
I'm sorry I'm sorry that you guys can't
hear the game right now but I'm doing
the best I can and I'm doing
phenomenally what I wanted whatever what
I was trying to say be fool was that
right now
Oh now punish a path of the punish the
punishment was death for my
unquestionable failure I gotta get that
I gotta just try to you can't push this
other voice out of your head because
it's your own fine
okay I'm back to I back to back to where
I was when I was ended the game before
but I don't know how about to borlaug or
hunger I could longer I could I don't
know how much longer I could take this
because I am literally going and sayd
your breath your brain cannot handle
what is going on in your head
stitch then let me get let me god oh my
god I can't do that that is oh shut up
me ah God I'm done wow that was so
horrible god damn that was the worst
thing I hope that was even a pair of
unbeatens sound now hear something of my
headphones back on now okay yeah now
everything's fine everything's much
better now my god that was awful
and I don't know if I said this but the
reason I had to switch to these ones if
you could even understand it's because
to do this you need to be able to close
out all other sound so these are my old
feds phones these are my new headphones
and but these are open ears you've got a
mess so you can hear so I had to switch
to these in order to be able to hear
myself but now I'm Gabel to speak
perfectly clearly I don't have this damn
delay on myself and rah that was awful I
wouldn't wish that upon anyone else ever
try it for yourself the program the
program is free and you I'm glad got
stutters still just cuz I can't
anyway the program is free it's called
speech jammer light you can find it for
yourself you could tell house you can
try for yourself if you want to put
yourself through that torture it's
really not pleasant it's not pleasant it
kind of made me go out of my mind there
nor more than I normally would so if you
liked it and you want to speed to
another game with speech jammer let me
know the comments below if you're
another youtuber and you want try for
yourself it's not copying go ahead try
it I don't even know if this was even a
little bit entertaining for anybody to
watch but you give it a try do it any
other anyone else could do it I don't
care I'm out I'm done so thank you all
so much for watching click in and it
takes for more videos that i've done and
as always I will see you in the next
video